- [DJ Cipha Sounds] Wow!
Wow. Chris (bleep) Turner.
(bleep)
- So my dream is to become
a rapper, that's my goal.
And I know it's going to go well,
cause people laugh when
I tell them it, right?
But I love rapping.
And so, we're blessed here
to have one of the finest DJs
in all of hip hop, Mr. Cipher sounds.
If we can please welcome
him back to the stage
with a round of applause.
Thank you. That's what I meant.
- Welcome, a pleasure,
oh, Matt's coming as well to vibe.
- [Matt] I'm just here for the party.
- Oh, yes. That's what I like.
So, what I love doing is freestyle rap.
That's rap made up on the spot,
based entirely on suggestions.
It's not written, it's not prepared,
it's not rehearsed.
So for that, I need you
guys to get involved.
I need you guys to think
of what you would like a rap about.
So, everyone here, think
of a word, a topic,
or a phrase you'd like a rap about.
There are some guidelines,
don't come up with foods and animals,
they're most common, most boring things.
Nothing too unimaginative.
Don't say stuff that
you've heard me talk about
or seen in the room,
and be creative, right?
Feel free to be like crazy.
The best suggestion ever
was a German man who said,
a day in the life of an Aztec high priest.
(crowd laughing)
I should be fair to him,
when he said it, it was
much politer than that.
I can't do a German
accent that isn't angry.
I feel like that's the
fall of their language,
rather than me.
- [DJ Cipha Sounds] What about yesterday?
You had a good one.
- What happened yesterday?
- Blow jobs for clam chowder.
- Blow jobs for clam chowder,
for someone in a chair over there, yeah.
- That was a good one.
- That was a good one as well.
So feel free to be
either German or filthy.
But you can say wherever you want.
So we'll come over here,
what would you love to
people like a rap about?
(crowd chuckling)
This is all of your thinking time, guys.
- Come on, help us.
- [Chris] This is anything.
- [Audience Member] Gouda cheese!
- What?
- [Audience Member] Smoked Gouda cheese.
- Smoked Gouda cheese.
That's specific enough that
it bypasses the no food rule.
Smoked Gouda.
(crowd laughing)
- Try to pay attention to the rules, guys.
- I appreciate you adding cheese
in case you thought I
wasn't cultured enough
to know what Gouda was.
(crowd laughing)
- I'll be smoking Gouda Gouda, son.
- Smoke that Gouda all day.
- Let's come to you guys over here.
So for suggestion number two,
what would you like a rap about?
- [Audience Member 2] Smegma!
(audience groans)
- I feel if we've got
cheese, that covers it.
(Matt retching)
So let's get something different.
- [Audience Member 3] Sex wings!
- Sex wings?
- [Audience Member] Sex swings!
- [Chris] Oh, sex swings.
- [Matt] Oh, swings.
I was like, who the fuck
eatin' wings and fuckin'?
- [DJ Cipha Sounds] I like sex wings.
- That sounds like my kinda girl,
you got sister or something?
(audience laughing)
Don't play with me.
I get them bitches blue cheese.
Fuck around if you want to.
I love sex wings.
(audience laughing)
- So, sex wings and smoked Gouda.
Let's come to the middle of the room.
What would you guys like a rap about?
(audience giggling)
- Jump in, anybody. Come on.
- [Chris] Don't be shy!
- [Woman] Jews!
- [Man] Zookeepers!
- [Chris] Wait, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
- [Matt] Jesus Christ.
- You made a suggestion,
that this woman went, it wasn't me!
- [Matt] She just goes, "Jews!"
- You said Jews,
is that correct?
- [Matt] What about 'em?
- Okay, okay, and what about them?
- [Matt] Somethin' specific.
- [DJ Cipha Sounds]
Something Jew specific.
- [Woman] The yarmulke.
- The yarmulke. Thank you.
- [Matt] What about the yarmulkes?
(audience laughing)
- I feel like we're being quite mean.
Do you also do also call
them kippahs over here?
- [DJ Cipha Sounds] Kippahs?
- Yeah or no?
In the UK, they're referred to as kippahs.
- [DJ Cipha Sounds] That sounds wrong.
(audience laughs)
- Isn't that the little fish?
- Yeah. It's a little fish, as well, yeah.
- That's delicious.
- Cause it looks like a little
fish, apparently, I dunno.
Cool, so, Jews, but yarmulkes.
- Yarmulkes.
- Let's come to you guys over here.
What would you like a rap about?
(audience murmuring)
- Guys, you already seen
what we're doing here.
- I love how they just kind of unplug
and disengage immediately.
- [Matt] Slowing up the
momentum, come on. Anything.
- [Woman] Fresh pussy.
- Yes, yes! Thank you.
- Fresh pussy?
- Yes. Not that stale pussy.
- Not that fuckin' expired shit
that you forgot in the fridge.
- No, not that chunky milk pussy.
We're talking about fresh.
- [Matt] It's all wilted
and leaking in the drawer.
(audience laughing)
- Fresh pussy!
- Straight off the shelf!
(audience giggling)
- Jews, smoked Gouda cheese,
sex swings, and fresh pussy.
- Muah!
- People over here, you are
the final people to come to.
You've had all the thinking
time, what's it going to be?
- [Two men] Dick-out ninja!
(audience laughing and applauds)
- [Matt] Hey!
That was the last in tow,
didn't prepare them!
What the fuck are the odds
that two random guys
would reference my most
embarrassing moment?
Fuck.
- [DJ Cipha Sounds] Wow.
- So, Mr. Richards, for me,
who was not here for that,
give me a brief pressing.
- Real quick, I dressed up
like a ninja with my dick out
to surprise my girlfriend,
and it didn't go the way I planned.
(audience laughing)
- He had pressed record on his camera
to make a sex tape,
- She walked in laughin' her ass off,
which immediately made my dick go away.
- Yeah.
- [DJ Cipha Sounds] Come on, Chris.
Dick out ninja,
everybody knows what the fuck that means.
- It was supposed to be
Chris Farley's next movie.
(audience laughing)
- Alright. You ready?
- I'm so excited.
As we said, a freestyle
made up on the spot,
based entirely on the suggestions
of smoked Gouda, sex swings, fresh pussy,
Jews, and yarmulkes, and dick out ninja,
completely improvised.
Matt is getting into,
yeah, yeah, no that's perfect and safe.
If you can drop a beat,
let's enjoy ourselves.
This is a fresh beat for you guys,
it's super exciting,
you seem so uncomfortable,
but don't worry, you can trust me.
♪ Eye contact, I know you can trust me ♪
♪ We popping off like a
nice whiff of fresh pussy ♪
♪ Oh, I feel it, get a thrill, ♪
♪ Open it up like a peel cling film ♪
♪ Like I open it up ♪
♪ Fresh out of the package ♪
♪ If I see a pussy so
fresh I'll attack it ♪
♪ And I mean in a nice, polite way ♪
♪ Only go up to pussy
consensually (manners!) ♪
♪ When you get consent
and you serve it up ♪
♪ Yeah, like ooh, steaming ♪
♪ Hot cup of tea ♪
♪ And just like me ♪
♪ A British rapper ♪
♪ To compare it, a synonym
is coming so naturally ♪
♪ I don't want it dirty ♪
♪ But you're making eyes at
me and I'm feelin' flirty ♪
♪ I be like, that's okay, yes I like ♪
♪ I might go after the
pussy with a baby wipe ♪
♪ I'm gonna clean that ♪
♪ Gonna make sure ♪
♪ It be lookin' nice ♪
♪ Yeah, what you're good for ♪
♪ Coming back here, we can be on our own ♪
♪ Start moving around on
the ceiling of my home ♪
♪ I to make sure I had
the roof reinforced ♪
♪ Why? 'Cause I got a
sex swing, of course ♪
♪ Using all of the chains ♪
♪ Ever so clever ♪
♪ Momentum on the lever ♪
♪ And the paddle is leather, rockin' ♪
♪ Sit on there and it gets so sweaty ♪
♪ Fresh pussy on the sex swing ♪
♪ Gettin' wetty ♪
♪ When you're over there ♪
♪ I stand still and not
just move it over there ♪
♪ Time to kill ♪
♪ She be rocking to the front ♪
♪ Rockin' to the back ♪
♪ Comin' over here ♪
♪ It's a little Jewish hat ♪
♪ I see a guy ♪
♪ And he catch my eye ♪
♪ He's like, yo, Chris ♪
♪ I'm a nice rabbi ♪
♪ I say, let me see what you've
got on top of your dome ♪
♪ He be like, I got a yarmulke ♪
♪ I'm like, yo, bro ♪
♪ We used to call it a kippah ♪
♪ In the UK ♪
♪ He's like, yo, Chris, ♪
♪ What did you say? ♪
♪ I'm like, apologetic ♪
♪ I didn't mean to say it
was like little fishies ♪
♪ Like, no, Chris you did
a little Jewish diss ♪
I apologize
♪ He does a good job ♪
♪ Teaching all the Jewish people ♪
♪ Down at the synagogue ♪
♪ It's kind of weird she
was shouting at you ♪
♪ Like, yo Chris, you
could rap about Jews ♪
♪ Totally, fine ♪
♪ Yeah, middle of the finish ♪
♪ I like those Jews who
could speak that Yiddish ♪
♪ They could say shmuck ♪
♪ They can be true ♪
♪ They could go home and
eat some smoked Gouda ♪
♪ Why would they do it ♪
♪ What's the plan ♪
♪ You can only get the
best out in Amsterdam ♪
♪ They be in the Dutch place ♪
♪ I be keeping in touch ♪
♪ I'll be getting all the
Gouda and sucking it up ♪
♪ I'm like, this cheese ain't no joke ♪
♪ I love my fromage from
Holland when it is smoked ♪
♪ Yeah, I don't mean I
roll it in a doobie ♪
♪ Don't mean I got it like a herb ♪
♪ Yeah to me ♪
♪ You were like ♪
♪ I'm not sure this guy believes ♪
♪ What I'm talking about ♪
♪ So we'll add on cheese ♪
♪ Now I understand ♪
♪ I'm wavin' my finger ♪
♪ I know what cheese is ♪
♪ Like a Dick out ninja ♪
♪ Walkin' in the room ♪
♪ People's in the back ♪
♪ But they can't see me ♪
♪ In the shadows, wearing all black ♪
♪ I'm walking in ♪
♪ Leave a girl shrieking ♪
♪ Out with that Alaska ♪
♪ My dick's retreating ♪
♪ I'm like, she doesn't
like you, my friend ♪
♪ And it disappears fast like a shuriken ♪
(audience applauds)
(air horn blows)